[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
is the xiaomi me note 10 that i've been
using for about a week
for exactly one reason
it has a
megapixel camera on the back so that is
a wild number 108
megapixels but i should mention we have
seen this megapixel push in smartphone
cameras before i remember there's a
little streak back when i was in college
like we had a bunch of four and eight
megapixel cameras then a bunch of 12 and
then a bunch of 20 somethings and then
we got that 41 megapixel nokia lumia
1020
which for a while was basically the king
of smartphones and it was pretty good
but it seemed like every time we got a
new higher megapixel number then that
became the smartphone camera king even
though megapixels didn't mean everything
like just because something has a 16
megapixel camera doesn't mean it's
necessarily better than the 12 megapixel
camera in fact a lot of times it's the
other way around so anyway now i'm sure
you've noticed that we've sort of
settled around pretty much everyone
having 12 megapixel cameras but
108
megapixels like that's gotta mean
something there's gotta be something
there
right well let's start with what that
actually means the resolution of one
photo from a typical 12 megapixel camera
like the iphone is around four thousand
by three thousand so that totals around
12 million pixels 12 megapixels so the
same scene from this new xiaomi camera
comes in at 12 000 by 9000 which is
multiplied to get you 108 million pixels
or 108mb
so you're getting about three times the
vertical and horizontal resolution to
make these numbers and the file size for
me has ranged from about 20 to 30
megabytes per photo so it's pretty big
and you've probably already noticed
there are actually five total cameras on
the back of this phone the 108 megapixel
main camera then there is a 12 megapixel
2x telephoto
a 20 megapixel ultra wide a 5 megapixel
super telephoto at 5x and a 2 megapixel
macro camera and there's also two
flashes two pairs of flashes like it is
a lot of hardware clearly so much in
fact that it sticks out from the back of
the phone and you end up like with it
rocking on a table and everything but
that's the sacrifice you make if you
want all these pixels and all this
camera quality so the question is
how good do the photos actually look and
the answer is really good
sometimes
so i said before there are a lot of
things that contribute to the quality of
a smartphone photo color accuracy
exposure dynamic range contrast etc but
the main thing you're gonna notice of
course with such a high resolution here
is sharpness and detail the photos in
the 108 megapixel mode are significantly
sharper more detailed than any other
smartphone i've ever used especially
when you give it a lot of light so in
the daytime under bright lights
basically
but i will modify it to say this it's
mostly center sharpness see the center
of these frames are super crisp and
sharp but when you move out to near the
outer edges and corners of the frame
it's rarely anywhere near as sharp this
is a perfect example in the center here
you can see the details in this merch
the fibers in the cotton you can
practically feel the softness i mean you
can feel the softness in person for
yourself everything's back on sale at
shop.mkbhd.com but yeah you get the idea
super high detail here but the edges of
the frame especially the corners
get very quickly distorted and fall out
of focus even on flat landscape shots
like this which is crazy you still have
that lack of center sharpness normally
if you have a subject in the middle of a
frame and you want that tack sharp focus
and don't really care about the edges
then that's fine but in a landscape or
something wider you really notice the
edge distortion i think a great way to
show this is to give context so iphone
11 pro we all know great set of cameras
i could use any other pixel 4 or a
high-end smartphone system but i took
the same photo on iphone 11 pro
and me note 10 back to back
12 megapixels
108 megapixels so here's an alleyway
very similar of course with each photo
different color temperatures slightly
different exposures a little bit but
again pretty similar uh but the
advantage of so many pixels as you can
zoom in and keep clarity and there's
you're actually kind of able to read
this tiny security sign over here on the
xiaomi where it's literally just blurred
lines on the iphone here this shot of
the river is pretty similar where you
zoomed out you'll notice the xiaomi is a
little more contrasty while the iphone
is a bit more flat that's typical keeps
more shadow exposure detail but as soon
as you zoom in again you start to see
the difference in levels of detail
especially in the trees and really
anything that's near the middle of the
frame like the links in the chain link
fence with 108 megapixels versus 12 is
super obvious and the theme keeps going
kind of no matter what your subject is
as long as it's in the middle of the
frame when you're zoomed all the way out
they're pretty similar with their images
it's just the iphone usually being a bit
flatter and then zooming in gets you
this immense amount of detail and
sharpness and this stayed true in
well-lit shots it definitely falls apart
pretty dramatically though in low light
the iphone has significantly less noise
so it does way less noise reduction in
low light and has not so much smoothing
to do because of it while the xiaomi
software is struggling and smoothing
over everything to the point where 108
megapixels with all this noise reduction
is less detailed than 12 megapixels with
excellent image processing so we've sort
of known it already but software is
clearly a big part of a camera's
experience and i can't talk about this
camera without actually talking about
the photo taking experience not just the
image quality but using it for starters
there's a separate mode for taking 108
megapixel photos typically when you just
open the camera in photo mode you're
going to take scaled roughly 27
megapixel photos still high-end that's
still a lot of pixels but that's where
it performs well you can zoom in and out
and with the extra lenses you can get to
2x to 5x and then even further with
hybrid zoom macro shots are cool there's
the ultra wide it feels fairly solid but
then you switch over to the 108
megapixel mode and things slowed down
quite a bit now there's a noticeable
shutter lag of over a second as it
captures the entire 12 000 lines of
resolution
and processes the whole frame writes
them to the not so fast storage and then
you can't view the photo you've taken
until after another few seconds of that
processing and writing the photo and
then you can see it sort of spinning for
a bit and once it's done
you can view it and once you view the
huge photo it doesn't actually load the
whole image right away it loads a
smaller proxy until you actually zoom in
in which case it decides oh okay you're
looking for that extra resolution and
then it loads up the full size preview
and you can see it sharpen up and so
it's doing all this mainly to avoid
having you deal with that not so great
experience all the time it's smart but
this is not the highest end phone in the
world i'd call it
upper mid-range specs are you know a
snapdragon 730 g chip and you're looking
at six gigs of ram and 128 gigs of
storage as the only spec and so in
general it's not going to be the best
equipped for spitting out 20 megabyte
image files and manipulating them in
real time the rest of the phone i'd say
is actually pretty well considered if
you ask me it's really solidly built
you've got a 5 260 milliamp hour battery
and there's a 30 watt fast charger in
the box and around the front i don't
like the curved screen i've talked about
that before but generally the display
itself is nice it's a 1080p amoled with
just that small notch at the top
there's an in-display fingerprint reader
there is even a headphone jack and an ir
blaster and you can see it's running
xiaomi's ui miui 11 on top of android
which has plenty of its own quirks and
features definitely an improvement over
the previous version from what i've used
but clearly still skinned so overall my
take is it's pretty sweet that we have a
legitimate like an actual 108 megapixel
sensor that can fit in a smartphone
today like just for the number on paper
that's really cool it's not some faked
composition adding up detail from three
different cameras it's real is it good
yes
sometimes
it's it's legitimately really useful to
take like landscapes and be able to use
that center of frame which is super
detailed and crop it and do whatever you
want with that but the sensor is so new
and so big that the image processing
pipeline makes not so great photos of
close-up subjects and low-light scenes
so it's clearly not flawless i really
became most interested in the camera in
this phone because of the rumor that
some camera phones next year
specifically galaxy s11
will have a 100 plus megapixel sensor
that is exciting because that's going to
be on a higher end phone that can put
the resources towards making that a
reasonable experience faster storage
higher end cpu more ram just more
processing power and then you of course
get a more tried and true samsung image
processing pipeline so all these things
can maybe make 100 megapixel smartphone
photo normalized and normal feeling
instead of sort of
like an add-on or an extra mode which is
the way it is on this camera so i'm
excited for that potential future not
just for the number on paper but because
of the actual improvement we've seen in
smartphone camera tech and just camera
tech in general since those uh nokia
lumia 1020 days
fingers crossed we don't lose sight of
that
either way
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
this portion of the video is sponsored
by nordvpn so a virtual private network
secures your internet traffic
encrypts it and routes it through a
remote server so it essentially protects
it through anyone locally trying to
snoop on it's one of the most popular
and secure tools that you've seen people
using to protect their data including
myself so nordvpn is offering 70 off the
three-year plan which comes to 349 per
month plus four additional months free
and so you can find out about all this
at nordvpn.com
mkvpn or you can check out the link
below
so that that's a pretty wild number
we've seen 108 megapixels
no we haven't